[Music]
the mother of the children killed in the
crash as well as her brother speaking
out tonight erlinda zakaria says there
are no words to describe her pain and
suffering sally jaramillo is live where
memorial is growing now for the family
sally
herlinda zacaria says her brother and
her children were her world all of them
had big dreams and aspirations now it's
just her and her husband having to bury
them the world turned apart by a driver
not following the rules of the road
all my family my kids my life so i lose
everything all the rules and nobody's
here only us
seven lives
lost too soon a mother trying to
comprehend what happened on saturday it
is very painful for all my kids herlinda
zacaria says while she was at work the
kids and her brother went to the park
they planned dinner together when
zacharias didn't hear from them she felt
something was wrong she started heading
to their location i just see everything
broken i waited until they told me
it was an accident there was vero all of
them fernando jeshua mejia 5 adrian
zacharias 10 juvia dailensa carrillo's
13 brian axel zacarias 15 gabriel mejia
barrera 23 david mejia barrera 25 and
brother jose sacarias caldera 35 years
old my son brian he was he was so happy
because next year he was
she was the medicine and he was started
working zacaria says she worked and
lived for her kids and never thought she
would be the one burying them all at the
same time people don't don't pay
attention how they drive they don't know
who they can kill zacarias wants to see
more speed limits and stronger
consequences for those running red
lights where it was his mind how he was
drunk or drunk i don't know as for her
kids and brother her message
she loves them and that her heart is
destroyed as they are her life
back out live sacarias wants to thank
the community for all of the love and
support she has received she wants to be
able to reach her gofundme goal as she
hopes to send her stepchildren to mexico
to be buried as they too have families
there if you would like to help visit
our website eightnewsnow.com for now
reporting live in north las vegas sally
caramillo live local now